okay I will admit I'm busy but I was
like oh I'll play the wolf among us
episode three when I have a chance what
you could argue I had many chances over
the course of the past couple weeks but
I finally played it and I was
immediately at the end like why didn't I
play this right when it came out the
wolf among us episode 3 a crooked mile
yeah I'm gonna talk about spoilers in
this episode I figured screw it let's
just go with it games like two weeks old
anyway if you were gonna play it you
played it by now I feel like the entire
world played it before I did put the
wolf among us episode 3 your Bigby wolf
is spoilers for episode 2 when you left
off in episode 2 you saw that Ichabod
Crane was taking really creepy pictures
of chicks he was making look like Snow
White and these chicks are dads are like
goodbye crane kill them right off the
bat I was like there are a lot of creeps
in this world and they use glamour they
can look like other people so I don't
actually buy the Ichabod Crane actually
killed them not until I have the
evidence this episode goes farther and
you know you want to make Bigby wolf a
nice guy you show up to a funeral right
out the gate you be like a snow stop
talking at the funeral screw that noise
she's a dead [ __ ] no one gives a [ __ ]
but I backed up I was respectful I was
like it's a funeral all right away for
Snow White to get done besides there's
really cool stuff on the table over
there and we'll get some lore out of it
Tweedledee and tweedledumber dicks can
just say it can we just get that out
there they're such dicks they show up at
the funeral with shotguns on my back
Oh big P wolf you I toy shy
I like Bigby wolf because as much as I
try to be civil when civility is needed
I will tell these people I'm like this
is the wrong day to pull this you don't
do I'm gonna shove that up your ass I'm
gonna shove the shotgun up your ass that
wasn't an option to say but it really
should have been because I was really
you can tell that people in this world
are starting to see big people through a
different life they're like Gina maybe
he's not such an [ __ ] depending on
how you play I played it to where
they're going in maybe he's not such an
[ __ ] cuz I'm not an [ __ ]
that kid fool anybody I wish I could
have just kicked in the door and be like
hey kid I know you're the witch stop it
stop it
kick the kid in the face be like I
didn't kick it get in the face I kicked
an old lady because I know that's the
witch in this episode also there are a
couple times where you can conflict with
Snow White kind of undermine her
Authority or you can agree with her and
for the most part I agreed with her and
then a couple times was like
they're gonna hire the old bat if for
nothing else keep your friends close and
your enemies even closer this chick is
making bootleg glamour she has a tree I
feel like if I burn her tree she's gonna
commit suicide it's a twitch we might as
well just hire her no I didn't like that
I felt like I lost points but I was big
me wolf
I'm still trying to hit that what this
isn't a Bioware game you can't have
romances I feel like you could but the
ending comes and the ending is so hot
it's so cool I was like yes all the time
yes you have Ichabod Crane is clear that
I mean he's a creep but he didn't
actually kill anybody he just jeez this
guy's a creep no crime against being a
creep oh so you're like all right you
pathetic bastard come on you're
embezzling money so we're gonna arrest
you for that [ __ ] Tweedledee Tweedledum
and Bloody Mary ya V Bloody Mary that
you've never had the guts to shout in
the mirror three times they show up they
want Ichabod Crane of course they go
tell them to shove the guns up their
asses and then they just start shooting
Bigby wolf you're like big me wolf isn't
dead though he's not dead because he's
big me wolves in his eyes go Incredible
Hulk but like yellowish-orange you're
like oh holy [ __ ] you spam that ex buddy
he starts wolfing out and they shoot him
he's like terminators but he's still
walking towards them look I am gonna
wreck these two [ __ ] sure enough
you beat the hell out of Tweedledee and
Tweedledum best part this is the part I
first of all it's pretty gratifying cuz
you finally wolfed out so I have
Tweedledum up Weyland I think it's dumb
l-look those [ __ ] look the same
anyhow I have Tweedledum up and it gives
me the option Thank You game Thank You
telltale games forgiving me this option
it was like kill him or let him go and I
was like you know what [ __ ] this [ __ ]
I jerked his throat out snow white's in
horror I'm looking over at her like I I
don't think we're banging anytime soon I
think the [ __ ] get Ichabod Crane
and that's it was just funny because
then it gives you the tally at the end
it's like okay X amount of people did
these decisions that you also did and
for the most part it's unanimous it's
like 87% of the people did not burn the
old lady's tree 97% of people waited for
Snow White to finish talking at the
funerals didn't want to be [ __ ] for
the most part people in the world are
like we're we all agree what is right
and what is not right except for the
Tweedledum
that thing 47 to 53 47% of people who
play the game they agreed with me
they're like nope that breve you so next
time they like if people find out what
you did to Tweedledum they're gonna
think you went back to your old ways I'm
just like whoo-whoo so they will mess
with me now I'll get answers out of
people Jack the giant slayer is gonna
lie to me now sorry Captain America
t-shirt douche bag you're not going to
tell me what you know the wolf among us
episode three was great I love the
investigative aspect I loved the
character building I loved the fact that
it let you just lose control and rage
out into a wolf and kill one of the
[ __ ] moment of silence for him sure
alright that's done that he doesn't
deserve any more than that there was a
moment and it's gone I'm loving it I
can't wait for episode 4 guys the wolf
among us episode 3 a crooked mile have
you played it what did you think about
it where is that comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]